okay I have a big announcement to make
we are going to be having a David Pakman
show chess it's not really a chess
tournament because it's just going to be
one game at least initially but the
background on this is that I casually
mentioned in a story a few weeks ago
when people said hey David are you Dee
Pakman on chess comm and I said yes I am
I'm Deepak Minh on chess comm I've been
playing chess on chess calm but I'm
terrible the chess playing contingent of
the David Pakman show audience just
exploded and I got like 50 or 60
challenges on chess comm from people I
accepted many of them I lost most of
those matches because I'm not very very
good but there was a big demand for me
to play a game of chess against producer
Pat now Pat unfortunately plays chess
even less than me so what we're going to
be doing is a live chat where it will be
Pat and Max producers Pat and Max will
be facing off against me and a live
chess match it will be live streamed
when we get to 2,000 patrons at
patreon.com slash david pakman show okay
and our patreon page has really suffered
over the last few months and really this
all started when patreon announced that
they were going to be passing on a bunch
of the fee for each payment to the
patron and even though they eventually
backed off of that policy change it
really irreversibly hurt us because a
ton of people cancelled their patreon
pledges so the pitch is we are
recommitting ourselves to growing the
patreon base of support we have we are
on the brink by the way of announcing
that the show is going to get about 10
percent longer every single day because
we are going to be removing more
commercials from the show we are doing
all of these things in order to improve
the program but they do come with the
sort of accounting reality that we've
got to make up some of that loss patreon
money okay so it does not matter to me
whether you make a pledge of a dollar
twenty-five dollars a thousand dollars
doesn't matter what it is dollar pledges
if we get 140 or however many it is that
we need dollar pledges we get to 2,000
we will have this live chess match and
we
been talking a little bit we were even
talking a little bit Pat rather about
the possibility of maybe offering
tickets to people who want to come into
the studio to be here live for the chess
match which we will be live-streaming
the logistics are a little tough I don't
know
what the cutoff would be for a
contribution but I think that this is
going to be absolutely a stunning are
you starting to prepare oh yeah it's
been a lot of long nights in the library
you know playing as much as I can I
think you should be shaking in your
boots because while you may be the
superior chess player right two heads
are better than one and I think we got
your number yeah and it's not going to
be a game where the time limit will be
so short like if it's really a fast game
like five minutes on each side or even
ten minutes on each side conferring with
someone else can be difficult because
you very quickly start to run out of
time and we would prefer that the game
not end on on a time loss but rather on
checkmate or a draw of course so I think
that we're gonna do 15 minutes for each
side meaning the game could be a maximum
of a half hour which I think Pat would
give enough time for you guys to confer
about what your next move is going to be
I think a half an hour is plenty of time
of course if we win that's great for us
if we lose the game was rigged yes
though I'll be a sore loser about it and
you know the truth is I I would not be
surprised nor would I be offended if
people start reaching out to Pat with
advice on hey listen here's the opening
you should consider because it gives you
the best sort of statistical chance of
at least being in this thing I think
also we're deciding that since I play
more chess than Pat and max I think I
don't think either of them really play
chess that I we will not leave who plays
black and who plays white up to chance I
will let you guys play white which does
confer a slight advantage and I I think
most chess players I know my win
percentage is higher playing as white
than black so I'm willing to concede
that right off the bat is smack-talking
big in the chess world because I'd love
to do some of that it's not really
because most people disable chat so that
they're not tied up with riffraff like
that but I mean we'll be in the same
room so I think that that is certainly a
possibility so 2,000 patrons and we will
be doing a live chess match I think
it'll be a really exciting thing it'll
be community building and it will
I don't know maybe we would even do a
thing where if we get to 2,000 patrons
and do the chess match anybody who's
contributing at the $50 level or higher
gets to play me on chess calm all right
like that's it I think that that's an
interesting thing which wish we could do
so let's make it happen I'll keep you
posted and let you know what happens in
the next couple days